this week we are partnered with
hellofresh and Rocket money more on them
after the
reaction well hello there citizens of
the reject Nation I'm fresh out of the
shower still got a little bit of drizzle
on my hair so I'm feeling extra Suave
today Andrew Gordon how are you buddy
I'm doing good but I'm not in this movie
and it's a guy Richie film and I don't
understand see Let Me Explain we covered
guy Richie's Wrath of Manar in Jason the
thumb and we loved it yes we did and so
we wanted to continue with some guy
Richie films as promis so we're going to
continue with the man from Uncle is a
movie I've been wanting to see for a
very long time I honestly don't know why
I put it off for so long I've heard that
Henry cavell's really fun in this movie
so I figured yeah man let's keep this
train going all righty well you know
what to do leave a like leave in the
comments other guy Richie films you
really recommend I forgot to mention I
have seen the two Sherlock Holmes movies
right and I forgot he did those be sure
to subscribe and click the notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction
is up for something that might pique
your interest thank you to prepper for
helping to set down these highlights and
thank you to all who have follow us at
our patreon becoming super sexy rejects
that's where you get the full length
Reaction watch along where you sync up
with your own copy of The Man from Uncle
and we cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch
along included Andrew you ready let's do
it
this is giving me Oceans 11 Vibes I was
about to say that but I let you do
it World War II ends Germany split
between East and West I think this is
based on a television show I believe so
y oh yes right cannibal hamers in
[Music]
this 196 63
okay damn look at this production yeah
holy crap this
sets wow this feels like Superman more
Aesthetics so good that's Suave Suave
should have worn my
suit I like how he's using like zoom
lenses that are like a 60s movie like
the actual film aesthetic looks like a
60s
film
hey great angle from down look it up who
are you and what do you want I'm here to
have a friendly chat about your father I
don't have a father I I don't have a
father I mean your real father Dr Udo
teller Hitler's favorite rocket
scientist I've always wanted to meet
Hitler's favorite rocket scientist two
years ago he disappeared like Steam from
a tea kettle like Steam from a tea
kettle say
come
on oh my God The Details Matter until
now this was taken last week in row
which one is supposed to be my father
but if your father's knowledge gets into
the wrong hands things could get a
little messy you know end of the world
like that classical American Voice he's
doing what makes you think I know where
he is I don't think you do but I think
you know someone who does your mother's
brother Uncle Rudy I've also been told
that your father was never Act a Nazi
actually a Nazi I'm here to help it why
don't you help me with what if I had 15
minutes we' drink tea eat biscuits I
talk you laugh and we be on our way
unfortunately I don't so my offer uh oh
he's the Cal's coming Che little hotel
in West Berlin in less than an hour
Canal
Hammer stay here and spend the night
with the Russians hanging from a pipe
having your toils removed that is what I
was looking
for this performance feels more like a
TR additional Clark can Superman than
actual than the one we got from him I
love him as Superman I do but this feels
like the traditional portrayal in a lot
of ways like he's doing a great job
embodying the era like it's a little
hiding but it's still believable are
they still following us
yes yeah he's charming and swab yeah I
like how much fun he's actually having
used to seeing him play like real
serious brooding characters is there one
of them hum if there is is he looking at
us he wants to eat
[Music]
her wow a great D Dutch angle that's
cool when you hear something that sounds
like a
gunshot
drive this is
suspenseful oh oh whoa whoa that early
you know a gunshots coming but somehow
that still got
you let's just hope he doesn't drive as
quickly as he
[Music]
moves must not be used to silencers this
was still pretty loud wow wow
wow oh this is a blast already take a
right and then an immediate
left he has to read like an actual
physical
[Music]
map
oh great stunt work holy [__] wow
damn amazing oh with these like classic
vehicles
too hold
[Applause]
[Music]
on smooth hell of a parallel Parker yeah
I need a rear view camera now to
parallel park right is he gone I don't
think
so
almost feels like the Terminator the way
he's like using his vision
reference Andrew reference number one
just number one and uh made me back
[Music]
here little tiny good little tiny good
for Army
Hammer wow he is so good at getting you
to follow a in a way that is very unique
and specific to KY
[Music]
Richie I loving the way this is
shot whoa
[Applause]
whoa wow and this moment then the James
Bond music comes on that emulates the
darkness
oo great reflection of the light
thereo Napoleon solo what a fascinating
name how skinny he looks
there badass and
intelligent like a spy and a
criminal love how they kept that Frozen
in the
play what a fascinating way to keep
subtitles feel like
[Music]
action finally that's such a Trope in
movies they never go for the
[Music]
tires oh his run reminds me of the
liquid Terminator
reference actually is pretty
similar and he's grabbing the back of
the
car he's trying to stop the
car oh my God God he's a
jackhammer oh we're struggling here why
don't you take a shot at him somehow it
just doesn't seem like the right thing
to
do whoa made you wait just long enough
to wonder if it was actually going to
fall in a FR this road isn't going
anywhere taking us exactly where we want
to go it's all part of the plan it's all
part of the plan refence red
soone boom is that c it looks like a
combination all we have to do is get
over two 20t WS in a mfi now
what oh my God that's so erotic take
another left through the window after
you it was all part of the
plan damn oh
hey oh my God the wrath of
hammer please don't eat me follow
me the music in this is
exquisite like I like how it feels like
classic the AAS dance music mixed with
the Spy fuel when there is a bit of a
cat and mouse dance to
them
what are we doing here we're looking for
agent
Jones Dr
Jones
[Laughter]
whoa
sick
this guy is
Relentless oh
[Music]
awesome erotic step
back you know Henry Cav would be an
amazing Bond because he's having a lot
of fun with the role but he's also got
the darkness so he could be like a
combination of a bunch of the arrows of
the bonds It's a combination of connory
and Craig play is in chic it isn't even
a hotel he's wearing an apron and
economic system on others is the primary
cause of World tension today this is the
year he was assassinated 63 I trust that
Miss taler was help the uncle off V trou
is the best Shan Uncle that's
jur I didn't ask you to line up half of
East Berlin they were waiting for me
don't flatter yourself they follow
everybody what was waiting for me was
barely human you should have seen it run
call it it like a Terminator we are not
in the habashy business I don't think
you understand it tore the back off my
car it it how long was your prison
sentence we can make it longer you owe
me five more years like the Devil he's
part of the suicide squad I don't ever
make the calamitous error of mistaking
my deliberate shortsightedness for
blindness I'd love the voices these
Brits are doing I sort of get the Vibe
of like cuz guy Richie is British of him
this is like an homage to the American
films he kind of grew up watching like
the action spy Capers could be way off I
tell myself solo that inside every crowd
there's an American trying to get
out anything in particular sir or are
you just looking what I'm about to feed
you solo might taste a little
better where are we going with this
uh they're going to have to work
together oh my God Henry cavl in a
bathroom fight I love it I understood
that
reference he just letting them work it
out dude come on Henry do the they are
fighting like the Terminators actually
yeah
[Music]
hey my best your best you
be I need subtitles I think that means
let him go just guessing or eat him what
does that mean he said don't kill your
partner on your first
day Miss tell's Uncle Rudy is a senior
executive the founder Sergio vinera was
a friend of molini and a known fascist
his son Alexander and his wife Victoria
who is this actor looks very familiar
all our information indicates ah ah
Elizabeth dicki Aisha from Guardians of
the Galaxy imagine the consequences if
he builds an atom bomb for them that
would be bad your mission should you
choose accept it and to retrieve Dr
Taylor and his research it will be
located in a computer disc and whoever
has that disc will simply be the most
powerful nation in the world W this is
like Mission Impossible yeah our Russian
friend will focus on Miss teller and her
uncle Rudy who's going to get the disc
and who's going to be okay with the
other one getting the
disc oh wow this is all just a big RSE I
love that or they all just SP finish at
the exact same time you understand
humiliation better than most after your
performance last night I thought I
should read up on you I love his
delivery your dad being a big palet
stalins and a top government official
with all the perks and privileges right
up until he was caught embezzling party
fun jesz were you when he was sent at
the gag 10 11 years old love this one
upmanship was that when the psychotic
episode started he's pay attention to
every little tick I do wonder if it was
your father's shame that gave you such
drive though psychologically profiling
him clever he knows how to get to his
core I love this Crescendo of the
music he has got a really bad temper
problem but I love that the like in the
Spy Thriller we're getting like a buddy
cop type of film now it's interesting
how Henry caval doesn't really view him
like human he treats him so much more
less than that yeah and it pains me that
the genre of the because of the genre
production designs like this don't get
recognized in like Oscar season and
stuff cuz this is Dro de gorgeous it's
beautiful this should tell you how
important this mission is to
everyone I'm not going back behind that
wall you're the star of the show my
woman would never wear anything like
that why did he call me his woman
because I am now your
fiance this is not part of the cover
he's just claiming her no no no no no no
no smoothly
done the stature and build of both Henry
caval and Arvy h on the safe screen an
interesting
contrast he's also managed to secure a
Visa for his fiance and naturally you'd
introduce him to your beloved Uncle Rudy
you just got to play along with it
what's your cover Jack devil Antiquity
Ste specializing in Greek and Roman
sculpture okay gets the most
sophisticated of them all Soviet
architect traveling to Rome would never
dress his woman in the clothes you try
to put her in you try to dress her like
someone on your side think someone
dressed behind the Iron Curtain she's
from behind the Iron Curtain Army Hammer
being controlling of a women not
likely
you can get back on your horse now
Cowboy I'll see you in Rome what about
the Americans playing the Russian and
the British guys playing the American
but it's missing a little
something now we are
engaged
congratulations he thinks he's so
sve it's fascinating to see like Army
Hammer play the stronger type stronger
character compared to Henry caval you
know like Henry caval is strong and
everything uh very skilled but it's very
clear that between like he's like Army
Hammer the the Jackhammer of the two of
them it's really interesting he's not
he's not the main muscle of them but
he's still a muscle but yeah for
sure I have a quick errand to run could
you have my bag taken to my room please
of course thank you dude they are really
nailing the look down oh damn she was
eyeing him I mean he's Henry C
the same place every architect goes when
they visit the own sure that happens
everywhere he goes oh my God this is the
staircase in every action movie bombs
happen and
stuff and these steps were constructed
in 1723 he making the [__] up credited
to to Italian Architects really built by
Russian Ser ianov sedge also had mother
who introduced him to classical
architecture and whom he revered
[Music]
as in memory of his beloved Yaga he make
one step to celebrate every year so she
died at
135 so she gave birth at the age of
65 evening comrade you're not supposed
to be making contact in public being
followed they divert when you turn down
the steps and they'll be waiting ahead
for you I will handle them I destroy
them someone is trying to make sure that
your fiance is really an architect not
someone who's trained how to fight KGB
agent for example you are not needed
here oh yeah you've got to play the yeah
I think you should do as he says and
remember take it like a
[Music]
[__] i' never saw the show Henry caval
was all this is usually the most fun
I've seen him have nice shoes thank
you perhaps you give them to me okay
give me some money for coffee give the
gentleman something for
coffee oh Western
standoff nice
watch wow oh did his father or mother
give him that watch give him the watch
and the ring oh damn these are all
personal items don't just give it up
thank you yeah without
hesitation he you look like you're just
voluntarily doing it give me the one the
[Music]
oh it's great set up for the coffee
scene to this or the table
soon no what are you doing man know what
are you doing
man calm down not very good at this
whole subtly
thing either you start to look like you
know what you're doing or I'm out of
here I will say cannibal Hammer
definitely brings a the hurt boy inside
of those eyes to this performance with
the compliments of the hotel I apologize
it wasn't brought up earlier thank you
very much is there anything else I can
do for you oh God it's a fine bottle of
champagne don't want to be alone ashamed
to drink it alone yes it would
be oh subtle I'm still on duty Mr Deany
so you got sick my shift ends in 5
minutes sure we can find something to do
for five
minutes so Charming couldn't tell if she
was like uncomfortable or what I was a
little confused on the way she was
handling it would you like bigger glass
I will finish this bottle are you going
to help me or not no thank you
disciplined Russian
not in the v i could see like the arcs
of of certain things they have to
overcome these two seems like Henry
cavali just going to be a
constant I like how she's kept slightly
out of
[Laughter]
focus this is not a good idea styles are
just such in
contrast no fan dancing by yourself I
need a
partner
no as you can dance is there supposed to
be like a romance form in between these
[Music]
two guess they're building towards
it and
then oh it's like how many more times do
I got to be slapped tonight now play his
rageb building
music you're not an East German Chop
Shop anymore still no drink don't you
make me put you over my knee what wow so
you don't want to dance but you do want
to wrestle I cannot say
that what is
damn throw about him fall
asleep Lua mender did that's
surprisingly realistic on that what if
it's all part of her plan to make him
calm down so is better than character
this time I do need to go that is
disappointing just another 5 minutes a
long 5
minutes his hair is perfect that's how
all our hair looks after uh 5 minutes
and what are you doing you're not
supposed to be here
these
are
Russian
made
these perfect and very L
Tech puts them down my bow tie doesn't
work with that
suit it's better for the mission that we
get to know each other a little bit more
intimately what does that mean it means
I like my woman strong strong going on
date we're going to
box bump the brakes we might be engaged
but I'm I own woman besides I wouldn't
be wearing my engagement ring it's only
just been stolen your fiance would have
gone out first thing in the morning to
replace it wow I nothing like this
person oh there he is
[Music]
you such Lush colors everything is so
incredibly vibrant in this it actually
feels lived in
[Music]
she's eyeing him I gotta say even though
obviously the emotional side supposed to
be with Army Hammer and Alicia viander
the movie is just way more entertaining
whenever it is with enry Cav's character
could you please come with me sir I'm
sure we can clear this
up
quy
y oh
I wonder what they do to people without
invitations I'm Victoria vua I do B of
an apologies in order I'll take it from
here thank
you oh she wanted to help him I think
every woman there wants to help
him I'm okay I think did he just put
something on her pretty sure he did you
I always thought Henry Cav was really
tall but he's surrounded by a taller
people than him in this film my favorite
niece uncle
Rudy Gabby you are a miracle worker sir
I want to hear all about how you manag
to get her out well I ripped the back
off a trunk and we went from there tell
me how does a Russian architect meet a
German car mechanic in East Berlin well
it started when I was brought out to
make improvements on 9 kmers of the wall
and one morning I was coming home he
rear ended a
tank I met the most expensive mechanic
in East G and did they make you build
the ball as well as design it ouch
you're shaped like a power lifter
[Music]
I like the joke yes that's how he gets
buff many is Jing jogging yes allow me
definitely how you build
uh oh apparently Henry Cav couldn't pull
it off they had to cut
away call me St
this well I doubt you'll miss
it trust him isn't
it
when did this happy accident occur 2
years ago I wanted to make sure it was
serious where perhaps ashamed why would
she be
ashamed Rage music but a good German
girl knows never to mix the blood of a
race horse but that of a cart Force
oh that's a fair it's not a fair point
okay that's not a very nice thing to say
don't be so protected sure a waight
can himself he's a jogger but I love how
they're zoning out the sound with like
when he's in Rage mode you're a thief
like to call myself a specialist in
complicated Acquisitions that's a fancy
way of saying Thief what is it exactly
that you think you can do for me Mr J an
important collection those one or two
special pieces that are impossible to
acquire without the the requisite skill
set Tony Stark always on the tip of my
tongue when I'm about to say something
you say
it
the hell Uncle
[Music]
Rudy he's got to take his rage out
somehow
yeah I need to use the
sink so use the ladies take it out
bathroom
flight nice to see you wly runs the
shipping department at British oil
excuse me I said I need to use this
there I love these Cuts back and forth
Jack Deon yes yes I think we bumped into
each other outside oh that's what he got
the invitation I do apologize not all I
noticed you're very good with your hands
oh excuse me he said use the ladies I
witnessed your trick with a table
Club oh my God they showed
it
want take I love the subtle
Jabs why how would you mess with this
guy he's
huge just remember if you're not first
you're last have the Jets been cleansed
and totally rechecked for sis and flop
you want to fix it oh show up God the
mechanic in her show them
up a I love this everyone's got
particular skill sets they're all just
groing in that's NE we don't even need
to see what he did to them I love it you
see each one of us is a destiny and I
believe I can help you with yours wow he
just totally switched the tune I can see
us have lunch tomorrow I'm engaged Dar
time to go sorry darling I'll be a
minute I'm flirting with this man being
spending a lot of time in bathrooms
recently apparently you put someone
called count Lippy in hospital he had
soft bones he had soft bones how did you
find Alexander migua I think he's an
athletic good-looking gazillionaire who
suffered me a j off and made advances
towards me yeah he might as well take it
is he trying to steal me away from my
fiance the answer is yes it's not
happening I don't know what you're upset
about you're not even my
fiance don't remind
me look at this this film I'm using has
been treated to be sensitive to gamma
radiation gamma blur lines here means
they've been in close proximity to
radioactive material in last 24 hours
which means they've succeeded in
enriching the uranium I'm want to go
sleep on
this I did think the movie's strengths
are at its best whatever it's like Henry
caval Army Hammer in the same room best
when all three are in the same room
together and sometimes I feel like the
movie kind of steers away from that
direction a little too much when I'm
like oh no it's it it's at its strongest
when they're all together yeah they have
really good chemistry the three of them
or just when it's on Henry Cavell
honestly I think he's the best part of
the movie oh by far it's not some Henry
Cavell Kiss Ass video he is the best
part of the
movie I think this movie is about to
give me exactly what I want wanted is
this what you call sleeping on it I
suppose you're responsible for the
lights you're welcome you have to work
together we are different but we are the
same I work better alone I work better
alone too I'm not leaving we have
approximately 10 minutes before the
power comes back on you s around and
talk about it okay I'll let you tag a
along but it's in and out no mess so
nobody knows we been here and we both
forget about in the
morning super Harden Boron sharpened
with a CO2 laser h
oh he got a laser oh goodness oh my God
the Russian Tech is so much better seal
to
laser just the laser itself love how
everything's always a competition with
them and you know there is like the spy
gadgets but they don't there's not a
heavy Reliance on them I noticed is
there anything I can do to help you be
quiet just let me do
it he's the thief he'd have a better
job
[Music]
[Laughter]
even when he's not delivering lines so
good that was a close one I love him in
this movie love
him no
awesome this looks cool but it's also
kind of conf using a follow at
times this
[Music]
watch I love the bombastic operatic like
rage it's like that tropea to Kill Bill
whenever they cut to him just so
dramatic when they play
[Music]
it
oh oh I I felt that he just left
standing oh what exactly did you do to
him KGB we call it the kiss it takes
years to master although he's standing
upright he's completely unconscious
he'll be like this for 20 minutes can't
touch 10 minutes are up why do you think
they have radiation tools and suit in a
satellite Factory for the atom
bomb next to Hidden
buttom we wouldn't have found that
without my father's watch Fair Point
your rage helped what have a
go be my
guest hold
this no one knows M like he is one of
the M I think like Edgar Wright guy
Richie they're excellent at knowing the
music for their films stronger than most
directors it has dual combination locks
triple return rotators and
synchronized cylinders so it's easy to
open the earlier model had a design flaw
I intend to exploit very difficult to
open but it's
not impossible wow great transition in
there impossible mission impossible
people who designed this model are not
very good mhm at stealing things they
should have had a thief created I
however am
that's such a great shot oh I love that
a reveal that it's mounted on the door
did you deactivate along model 710
doesn't have an
alarm loving your work Cowboy uh gy
Richard really knows how to make the
camera feel like a
[Music]
character action
sequence God you guys should warn masks
you should have warn masks the Freeze
Frame there cool like a photography shot
does this mean anything to you it's SP
of centrifuge for refining uranium I am
not staying here where are you going to
go
swimming
[Music]
wow
great comedic effect of knowing that the
sound design of what to keep in frame
and what keep out of
frame come on I got three exit and two
of them are
close I would recommend turning before
you hit that wall the last thing I need
is your help they going to jump the wall
they're really riding in that speed
boat oh my oh my God oh my God
no what have you
done he told him to shut
up he doesn't even realize he's off the
boat fantastic
editing the timing of that was
[Music]
perfect I really feel like when I'm
vibing with this movie I'm really vibing
with this movie at times there's like
certain pacing that can be a bit off but
sequences like this are just so
perfectly
executed share it with the concierge at
the hotel sit back and
enjoy you got a little the Superman
[Laughter]
curler
just got joy a whole
meal whose truck
is there's just
a just a whole meal here got picnic
dinner for two they're supposed to
have oh my
god
oh is he caring he's caring going and
get
him oh
whoa nice to get a moment where it's
just all
visuals is he going to get out he knows
what he's
do smart this allows him to see that is
so
smart saved him the cowboy saved me
[Music]
she's going to his
room it's the Nazi race car
driver
uhoh oh it's Uncle
Rudy he knows he knows he knows things
he didn't get places cuz he was
dumb they got a ferris sper
this got to get in there come on
guys and he's going to have to take off
his clothes quick sorry Mrs V there's no
answer key
key what's going on where's my
case dropped his accent there hello
Victoria uh come on in
[Laughter]
grape she's enjoying Those Grapes sure
Victoria believed you I gave it
everything I
had I also got another meeting with her
so what we just let Gabby go with Uncle
rudby if there's a chance he'll lead us
to fun
do we have a choice this could be like
leading a lamp to slauter going soft
Peril oh yeah your tracker is not
sending a signal you turn it on I think
so or do you want to check it be my
guest it's it's your threer you're the
expert I'll be on the
balcony your
fiance you're trembling that's because
I'm scared it's going to be okay how do
you know I'll be close
by I'll turn on
now yes they yes they are he is so good
good at
this fascinating audio choices
here oh I wonder who did
that he really likes to make the camera
feel like like he lets the audience feel
like a character it's it's really
interesting I no that we know wrath man
he definitely does that here like the
fact that they you don't get the audio
till the window's down really
interesting choice I know my father is
here and that he works for you and how's
that
simple think I've ever seen someone peel
a grape like that I think I need to make
a telephone call but perhaps you come to
us at a for Tous time Miss teller your
father's word cathic has been as of late
somewhat lacking your presence will
provide the necessary motivation oh man
that's not cool
even off Madame vua will be with you
shortly she would like it if you make
yourself comfortable every woman wants
to bang him help yourself to a
drink that's way he carries himself too
what's in that
drink oh no you don't look like you
slept much last night Mr devony F you
should say that Madame bigua don't think
this Scotch is helping either oh he
knows I would say you put something in
my drink called it much easier to trust
a drink you fixed yourself but how did
you know I was going to drink the scotch
I didn't I laced all the drinks smart
man I don't like to leave much to chance
I thought I was doing so well well don't
be so hard on yourself you were doing
fantastically well oh he's getting dizzy
you couldn't control the Loyalty of
young Gabby I know my father is here and
that he works for you and how's that my
fiance is a KGB agent am wife has been
entertaining with the
CIA the Russians and the Americans
thought they were using me but I was
using them to get to you damn it they've
been played it's a tracking device he's
probably out there in the woods watching
us right now it's re he's just so
annoyed he's like I've been here before
and last time I fell rather badly and
hurt my head I'm afraid that isn't going
to stop you getting hurt sleep
well whoa hello again Mr
SU
who turned the power
off we have contact so sorry I can't
stay to finish you off myself go she
says the most sexual things I'll send
you a cards to Little Gabby is this part
of their plan Little Gabby totally
betrayed the hell out of them don't see
how it would be unless Henry Cal was in
on it too wouldn't be surprising if it's
part of the plan but we shall see Cally
Army Hammer wasn't on in on it unless
he's just like I'm going to just pretend
to act annoyed for whose who sake for
the audience sake once upon a time there
was a little boy you wouldn't describe
him as particularly special little boy
he was neither tall nor handsome
charismatic or amusings like a Bor boy
he was bulu mercilessly and relentlessly
by the other children makes sense he's
boring what the other boys didn't
understand about their victim was that
he didn't see them as enemies subjects
man has only two masters in this world
and then names are pain and fear I say
love and fear he had quite a talent for
eliciting these feelings in others so on
the principle of playing to his
strengths he decided to make their
cultivation his life's work what a fun
way of showing the backstory history
gave him a World
[Music]
War oh colorized footage of it it's like
stock footage yeah I think it's Su they
take historical footage and then color
it in you will go here Mr
solo a whole page Just For You Solo
page it's okay Henry caval and Payne are
good friends he is not exceedingly dull
that's for
sure God they just nailed the
look I really feel like I'm in the 60s
when I look at this yeah a shot like
this looks like it looks like film I
mean I'm sure they shot digitally but
they convert it to look like film in a
lot of these shots I must admit does get
frustrating but fortunately I'm on an
oldfashioned I think we'll start with
the plers oh and he pissed him off the
their first time they met each other do
you mind you don't have to do things for
me to make me talk I'll tell you
everything you won't be able to stop me
what about the Gabby she betrayed you I
will
testify this guy just do you still have
teller yes has he succeeded in enriching
the urine we are way beyond that there's
already a war a nuclear warri
information torture they're sending a
submarine between that time and now it
is being held on vinara island he just
knows oh you can dish it but he can't
take it
uhoh it's your call you're the one he's
been having fun with uh too late one
hand we need it I love this out of focus
in the
background so what do you think we
should
do do you smell that
he fixed the
glitch left my jacket in
there think this whole reaction I've
just been saying I love Henry Cav in
this movie's he's by far the best part
he's so good and him an Army Hammer do
have really good chemistry man Dad I'll
let you two get reacquainted fem fatel
it's tragedy it's all part of their plan
it's tragic there's irony to it though
at the same time come out there's a lot
of slapping in this
movie solo meet again hey he was an
Insider we must give them an appropriate
welcome he will report to Commander wavy
of British Naval intelligence for the of
the mission got
it now it is vital you retrieve Dr
Teller and the computer Des but who's
going to get the computer disc kill the
Russian if necessary
oo yeah
oh exactly I knew that was going to H I
mean it's obvious they know they're
being told the same thing yeah ex of
course but they actually give a [__]
about each other now so there is also of
course the uh small matter of retrieving
my agent well she's not British oh
Gabby's working for you isn't she uh
well well done so yeah
oh the most he got there in the end
that's
what she was just waiting in the
mechanic shop the whole time I don't
understand he's ready out to resume his
work a daugh is touch Gabby has agreed
to assist me to assure a finish in time
you're right she is really tall she is
scary actually I did not notice when
Professor teller disappeared we assumed
that his Nazi colleagues would come
knocking at his daughter's door so we
recruited her okay that makes sense I
saw her betrayus at vinera yes I told it
the meeting is confirmed uh oh yes okay
that was well yeah I think it's rather
nice I mean we're obviously all very
fond of Gabby and now we have a chance
to to save
her so what is that there it's known as
a coupler it sends a signal which
enables another missile to lock onto
this one for double the impact you need
to do something to mess it up to nuclear
come on
Gabby I'm sorry we're nearly done
Victoria those are the words we've been
waiting to
hear
what are you doing let's both stop
playing games shall we put her in a Cell
kill her she is intimidating oh very
much so a computer disc with your
research on it where is
it and the backup o like no matter what
whatever agency has that like it's a bad
thing what about Gabby she'll be joining
you
shortly
no no way they killed the dad a poor
poor Gabby cool oh damn get the wi of
that and the POV of the scope that was a
really unique
shot it's like the James Bond credits
were it was an action scene with the the
red yeah yeah wa this is
wild holy [__] damn this is like a
gnarly ass at oh my
God
wow knows when to break the sound man
sound barrier closing and makes your eye
like pay attention focus
up
H the bomb was
here and the
discs mother's
watch
that's I like that they make the music
sound like gunshots too on that moment
when they Cuts away Alexander has the
bomb they're at the
entrance fortunately the bomb is
sabotaged but they still have those
discs oh my
goodness this this is
intense a it's drenched in the
mud
ah holy [__] no one were to lock off the
camera lets moments like this these feel
like make the stunts feel bigger than
usual
man Henry Cav was really behind that
wheel
woo that is
awesome oh my God that was
great this is a crescendo of a Chase
sequence
man h
oh oh gosh oh
crap oh
right oh I hope she's okay really love
they they know when it gets those
mounted shots from within that make it
feel just so much more
real oh
[Music]
crap he threw a motorcycle at
him that's
awesome you hit on my
fiance that was a great reveal
shot perfectly placed right next to him
yeah just one small snag wrong Warhead
ah she got away so it's a decoy no no no
it's a real bomb quite a nasty one too
but uh not nuclearized there's no
uranium in it
there was a second Warhead in the lab
that information would have been helpful
don't even know which boat we're looking
for he died 5 years ago having built
Vena into one of the biggest shipping
companies in the world every detail
counts de can you get them on the radio
if we keep them broadcasting for long
enough I have an idea which might make
things quicker what was her
[Music]
idea put Henry caval on it Deo this is
Napoleon solo I suspect that you're
already listening so I'll give you this
message directly earlier today I killed
your
husband he died honorably courageously
and selflessly but he didn't
psychological work it was a rather
pitiful Affair involving tears begging
and office to trade anything and indeed
anyone so that I would SP life yep you
get under someone's skin any blood
relation of yours still living will be
dead within a year there's nothing
you'll be able to do but witness their
suffering as you await your own death
this I vow on my husband's Soul you were
not faithful to your husband we have the
professor's disc we can build as many
bombs as we need I see one flaw in that
plan we've been locking onto your radio
signal now we have your general location
the coupling device that you so
considerately left us on your decoy
Warhead is accurate to 10 ft I have an
idea
[Music]
oh that Warhead although not nuclear
shouldn't have any trouble obliterating
a medium siiz fishing
boat yeah the aforementioned Warhead
launched ready yes proceed please
Captain 45 seconds
ago what a fun way to play with time
giving you about 30 seconds until impact
it won't trigger the nuclear warhead as
that requires fishing
they're all listening I suggest you
abandon ship immediately oh [__] how's
that for entertainment
ah
W what a reveal God this movie is so
good it feels like that that was really
good mislead because I wasn't exactly
sure what hug Grant was talking about
but I didn't even question that there
was something more of us I'm not going
back to East Germany no that is probably
not a good idea for a British spy sorry
I deceived you I'm sorry I really wanted
to tell you but it's okay I would have
done exactly the same thing in your
position we understand each other let's
kiss in case we don't see each other
again kiss you should keep it a souvenir
that way I can keep track of you eat
her Miss impeccable timing every time
they're about to kiss he looks so
annoyed
yeah I knew that was going to become an
issue at the
beginning his identity in this
regard that's where his rage stems
from he's his own man
though damn even without the sound you
feel
it
I really feel bad for the hotel staff
throughout the whole film here he's just
in
Conflict doesn't want to kill him yeah
they formed a nice little partnership
here and they care for each other come
in just finishing up I have your
father's watch let's be
friends politics being what they
are can't hide his tions you just cannot
play this yeah mission accomplished head
back to Russia suay like this
almost
forgot got something for
you my man I didn't see that coming you
know what my mission is same as mine was
doesn't want to kill him screw our
agencies it's form our own agency kill
me if necessary to get that let's just
leave it in the hotel room
yeah are they burning it yeah oh okay
that works too it's it's better that way
honestly but I've um spoken to your
superiors and now that we're all such
good friends they've kindly agreed to
let me keep the team together for a
while we leave in an hour where are we
going Istanbul kaken oh and you have a
new code name uncle
uncle so the agencies were just cool
with all
this
don't ah fantastic we need the sequel
the men from
Uncle
I'm trying to see if there's any details
here man Why didn't it get a sequel that
really bums me out I I got to assume box
office but I feel like it's become so
much more popular over
time and I think Army Hammer's career is
thriving and they should definitely
bring him back for a
sequel I mean it would definitely be
hard to do the sequel without him but
yeah I I hear you there a part like he's
he's fortunately if they ever got a
sequel he is really good say you need to
bring him
back I don't even know the full story
about the Army Hamer thing I just know
the jokes yeah true that are not so
funny if they are
true he eats women
right sure and he just got away with
it all right well let me see
this how am I supposed to pay attention
to the credits and read everyone's name
at the same time thank you to America's
number one meal kid hellofresh for
partnering with us it's always great to
partner with people who Services you
actually use because it's someone like
me who's always juggling a pack schedule
between filming and editing finding time
for healthy eating can be a challenge
that's where hellofresh has been a game
changer for my life with hellofresh I
get farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients
and delicious recipes delivered right to
my doorsteps so I don't have to step
outside it's revolutionized my home
cooking experience making it not just
easy but super enjoyable and affordable
keyw I recently tried their delicious
barbecue pineapple flatbreads and their
zucchini pomodora Panet bake both were
mouth wateringly delicious and fit
perfectly with my pescatarian lifestyle
pescatarian M sounds fancy and asking my
friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a
meat eater again people I know I've
really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken parar I think is how you
pronounce it in the fuo chicken fajo
tacos regardless hellofresh menu has
something for everyone but of course
it's not just about the food it's about
saving time too not having a wait in
line at a grocery store even self
checkouts on fast enough these days the
convenience of having everything
delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with her
quick and easy meals like 15-minute
recipes spending less time in the
kitchen and more time doing what I love
which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to
support the channel and also support you
know having a new lifestyle healthy
affordable lifestyle in the year 2024 go
to hellofresh.com reject free and use
code reject free for free breakfast for
life you heard that right one breakfast
item per box while the subscription is
active free breakfast for life for
hellofresh.com reject free use promo
code rejects free try it out and let me
know your favorite dishes stay healthy
and let's keep enjoying those movies and
shows all right reject Nation let's get
real for a moment running this channel
is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for
the channel and my personal life can be
overwhelming that's where rocket money
has been a financial Lifesaver for me
even before I ever partnered up with
them like I said I've been very
fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a
win-win for and why but it can be a
win-win for you too cuz there's a reason
I use them rocket money is a personal
finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and
crafting a budget that fits your
specific lifestyle for someone like me
who can easily lose track of expenses to
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye opening to see where I was
overspending stuff I don't use that I
kept paying for especially apps man I
was way too many apps rocket money does
the heavy lifting by analyzing your
spending then customizes notifications
to help you stay within your budget
goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly
subscriptions too so many free trials I
signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free trial was
done making it super easy to cancel the
ones you don't use couple of clicks and
you're putting money back in your pocket
telling you have you ever found hidden
subscriptions or pay for services you
forgot about because rocket money is a
huge asset in helping to uncover those
and even negotiate some of my bills down
to like 20% so if you're ready to take
control of your finances and there's no
better time than now because it is the
beginning of the year check out rocket
money and see how much you could be
saving stop wasting money on things you
do not use so to help support the
channel and help support your wallet
visit rocket money.com rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year over $500 million
in canceled subscriptions they've helped
me and I'm confident they'll do the same
for you that's rocket money.com rejects
your bank account will thank you we just
watched The Man from Uncle if you're
listening to us on Apple and Spotify
please go ahead rate this video uh and
yo okay so that would be great with
Andrew and myself we saw Wrath Of Me
recap our guy Richie movies Lock Stock
snatch you saw Rock and roller yes um
have you seen Aladdin
uh I saw the first 15 minutes well I saw
ladin I enjoyed it uh I've seen the
Sherlock Holmes movies have you I've
seen the first one but I don't really
remember it to be honest I just remember
the soundtrack Han Zimmer okay so yeah I
really don't remember it at all and then
we saw Wrath of man so there's a big gap
here of movies of guy Richie films that
we haven't seen so we saw Wrath of man
really enjoyed it tonally exact same
thing as man for moncle oh exact super
goofy totally
a Whimsical nature crazy production
design I almost thought I was watching
the same film I was like this guy does
not have variety this guy richy
whatsoever all uh no very different
experience and I know this one came out
uh first was 2015 just a couple years
after Man of Steel and didn't really
know anything about I heard it was a spy
movie but I I remembered seeing a
trailer but I couldn't tell you anything
from the trailer I recall and I I wanted
to see just because people had always
recommended the movie as like a fun spy
Caper and I got to agree uh I had I
don't I think there's some some flaws in
it that I would like to you know dive
into but I don't feel like I spend too
much time on it because what I think is
the intention of this film is that it
wants to you know have a panach style
the zest when it comes to the flavor of
the you know spy aesthetic the Spy genre
films and the shows uh from back then
haven't seen Man from Uncle but it
seemed to me at least the impression I
got is like seems like that like because
it's based on a show is that uh sure the
show I'm sure it's honoring in a lot of
ways but it seems to go further beyond
that and just honor a whole genre in it
of itself of a specific type of uh time
period And I think that you know guy
Richie one of the things about his
movies is Guy Richie is often one of the
stars of his own movies you know what I
mean and I feel like that personality
shines through and through I'm reserving
I'm I'm holding off on talking about
someone just so I can let you take the
lead on that and uh so yeah I feel like
that when it comes to this film like the
editing again is very solid in his use
of knowing how to work with his sound
designer of when to go in and out of
sound with soundtracks like there's I
feel like he creates such a good sensory
experience and I feel like this era was
really brought to life uh in a way that
felt like appropriately modern while
still hearkening back in a way that
didn't feel like it was I don't know um
you know uh biting off more than n could
Chew in a way that seemed like cheesy
you know like I get what you're doing it
still felt like lived in but still felt
modern and period piece simultaneously I
thought did a really solid job at that
with action scenes that I was dazzled by
like that that final one in the the
chase scene was uh brilliant in when
they're going through the island and
getting you to understand like the
distance the scope and and make it like
this craziness but also being able to
appreciate when it was one take or or
you could really feel the stunt man
behind it and the performers like it
wouldn't get lost in the edit I feel
like sometimes you know you watch like
the behind the scenes of certain action
scenes and you're like well it's hard to
appreciate it when I see the final
product just because of how it's
actually assembled and cut together but
here like yeah it's crazy but I could
keep up with it all and I'm able to
still it's like George Miller es and uh
yeah I I really thought that was great I
have held off onp talking about the man
of the hour Henry cell just for you I
was going to say I thought the best
character by far was Uncle Rudy I love
how they went into his backstory we got
to see why he's such a tortur um no no I
mean yeah Henry Cav I mean he just the
swaave the charm I mean the energy he's
just uh he's just so much fun to watch
you can tell too he's having a great
time while he's doing this too and I
mean I just I know we said it a couple
times but just watching this I'm like I
really would love to watch him we could
put it close closer we're not reacting
put it closer that we could hear you
clearer yeah there you go I I really
would love look that she the volume
difference you can hear yeah I I really
would love to see Henry caval as James
Bond one day I mean I think you said it
best too like he could Encompass you
know both that Sean Conor and Daniel
Craig thing but um also too I really
loved the chemistry he had the three of
them was really great but especially him
and Army Hammer and the way they're able
to build I mean because it it kind of
yeah it was a spy film but also like
turned in turned into a buddy I thought
you were flexing turned into like a
little bit of a buddy cop type film too
and you know they completely are you
know totally different signs sides of
the same coin type of thing but you know
they come to an understanding and they
uh I just I appreciated the the contrast
they are completely opposites of each
other and you know the way they you know
build a rapport with each other I just I
loved their chemistry and their
interactions were so good and you know
by the end of the film like you could
see that they have a full understanding
of each other and I really even though
it was kind of telegraphed and
predictable a little bit in terms of the
the watch thing it didn't bother me in
any way uh I thought that was a
beautiful moment in the film and Army
Hammer just I know we had all the jokes
through the reaction with uh you know
what's going on and what happened in his
personal life but uh I actually did like
his performance in it um and I just
again so polar opposite which I think
was necessary with this because you know
there was a certain uh level of charm
that Henry caval I think it was
appropriate to do the exact opposite
with army hamur um and I think that's
what works well I mean it's kind of like
the Lethal Weapon effect like Rigs and
merar are so different and that's what
why they're so perfect with each other
and I felt the same way while watching
this and um yeah and like you said too
the sound design so freaking good in
this movie I mean even at the beginning
right away just starting us off with the
silencer sound I mean I I mean I just
feeling that right away and also to the
um I love the camera work as well in
this too you had those reveal shots
where um starting off in the mechanic
shop where they're down below and then
uh when he was opening the safe this KY
Richie has such a a specific style and I
just you can always feel like he's like
you said he's his own character uh in
his own films and I just so appreciate
that but well let's the audience play be
a character with with with his at least
maybe he's always done that since snatch
and long stock maybe I just a notice
back then even though I love those
movies um but especially watching Wrath
of man and this like he he chooses his
moment he knows how to play with
perspective a lot especially a movie
such as this where you deal with
perspective and time and you go
backwards a little bit so that way you
could see what really went down or or
how certain reveals are are happening
and you got many different perspectives
here and sometimes he just gives you the
audience perspective in a very literal
sense where you get moments such as the
windows are shut you can't hear what
they're saying even though you're
following the characters with their
subtitles happening and the window goes
down some you could hear them and then
knowing when to uh have only music
playing and then want to snap the
audience back into it in the same shot
where they bring the music back a lot of
directors will rely on like do a punch
in here do a zoom do a cut and he
doesn't do that he'll just rely on the
sound whilst being in the exact same
shot or the exact same moving shot which
I think is uh very unique to guy Richie
and back to an earlier point
that you were making about the two of
them together it is a very interesting
contrast because there's a buddy cop or
buddy Spy you know it's
usually
um It's usually the way they usually do
that is one's the straight man and one's
like a little bit of a wild character a
little goofier you know that's the
generic way of doing it and like I said
don't know the show so I don't know you
know how accurate they are to the
characters in the show it's based on a
show right I believe that's true right
um but what I really liked about is they
did such a good job at individually
establishing Henry caval individually
establishing Army Hammer and they're
very unique to themselves and they
didn't sacrifice who they were in this
for the sake of writing like comedy back
and forth between them or writing banter
between them like it's a different kind
of dynamic than I'm used to when
associating it with the genre like not
one's not goofier necessarily stupider
or something like that you know they
they they each have their own skill set
and the respect level they earned for
each other felt like organic and genuine
and none of it ever like you always knew
it was going to go that way just cuz
it's a movie but so you knew it would go
there but how they got there was
actually done in a in a way that was a
little bit more
subtle and a movie that is also quite
Lively and large that that I really
appreciated how they did it because you
know Army Hammer's Russian spy character
is uh the more emotional one and one
with a lot of pain and they have these
this uh this touch where whenever he's
getting enrage like this dramatic
operatic music like overrides his system
and and you could feel like the the the
pain the pathos within this guy whereas
Henry cavell's a little bit more of like
your traditional American spy guy but
with a uh you know with there's still
that heart underneath it it's still a
Darkness underneath him but not so much
the extent of army hammers but they my
point is that when they have them
interact with each other they stay true
to the characters and they don't just go
let's make it a funny movie now let's
make it a a thing like they still feel
like oh they're very they're very
fleshed out um for this world that
they're in and and I and yeah man I
can't praise Henry caval enough in this
film he was he really I I heard he was
good mhm and but I didn't know he was
going to be like this this entertaining
like he really cuz here's the thing as
as good as Army Hammer I thought was
like my personal point of VI I thought
he was really I thought he was actually
really good in the movie I think Alicia
viander does a really good job too the
truth be told in when Henry caval is not
there you're thinking about it it's it's
just not as entertaining because you can
cut to Henry caval not with army like
the movies at its best when all of them
are together um
or or at least Henry caval and Army
Hammer however you can cut to Henry
caval being on his own not with the
other two leads and the movie is just as
entertaining in those moments like it's
it's a testament to the strength of him
as a performer in this film and to me
it's [__] like this that makes you go
man you really lost something there with
Superman you lost something there with
Witcher you really lost uh like a great
performer on your hands because I'm used
to Henry caval being more like the
serious brooding type like there's a
sense of humor that comes through with
him as geralt and The Witcher definitely
not to this extent he's still like for
the most part like a serious brooding
character and here he's not serious
brooding guy right um yeah but yet he's
like very believable still I like he
really is to me I'm like this is a star
performance yeah even in the the
mechanic shop and like when he was in
the car and like just hearing him just
how Jo how again the humor it's like you
even said it you're like this is like
the traditional Clark Kent that we would
normally like clar it's like a Superman
and bond you either one man exactly um
you know and speaking about Army
Hammer's character I actually really
liked the emotional Arc we went through
with the character you know again
feeling his pain throughout uh you know
what happened with his father and his
mother and then again seeing those
scenes of Rage with him uh I actually
liked that I thought that was really
organically done and then by the end
again very well earned I also thought
this film did a good job too I I it's
again a stylistic thing that guy Richie
does and it again very well earned in
terms of he'll say a couple L it's like
a subversion type of thing where he'll
say some lines you hear that lines of
dialogue and then it's revealed later on
either a couple minutes later or 10 15
minutes later where it's like oh this is
the rest of the scene and it's like I
just I love when he does that stuff it's
it's just very intelligently done and
then when it's and but he insert it like
it's edited properly and when he inserts
it it's like oh okay now I see cuz we
didn't even know what the plan was when
they were going at the end there uh when
they were trying with tracking the the
uh when they were trying to get uh
what's her name Elizabeth
Deli decki um when we were a little
confused and then when the plan was
being revealed like ah okay because when
they were fully you know shelling out
like exactly what was happening I just
thought he did a he did that a couple
times throughout the film but he's he
did that I believe in Wrath of man and
I'm sure snatch and some of the other
films that I can't remember the scenes
but he has a way of doing that I love
when he does it and it's such a
stylistic choice of his and I just so
appreciate those I mean it's not very
well a lot of directors and editors just
don't go that route because if you mess
that up it can really screw up the
scenes badly so but he really does it
well and he executes it in a way that's
methodical and just well really well
done you know in in a lot of ways I feel
like guy Richie and Christopher Nolan
are kind of cut from the same cloth like
they're like they're British they're
British and they they love to play with
time and uh they have a unique voice
unto their own with their like they're
very the emotions you're left with for
from their films are very different I
would say but there are things about
them that I find uh to be uh to be quite
similar it's just what you know you
associate Nolan more with The Prestige
of it all right not not just his movie
I'm talking about like him as a was an
art director and you associate more guy
Richie as like just entertainment you
know but but I think there really is a a
methodical attention and detail and care
that is truly lace throughout and and I
I don't know when it happened where guy
rich just started getting like kind of
not the greatest not hailed as like this
truly great because I think he is like a
fantastic director sometimes I think in
the first 45 minutes of this movie I
felt like okay the first 20 20 minutes
20 or so minutes was like really solid
and then it does get to a point where it
gets a little down I I felt with some of
the more like you kind of siphon off you
know our three leads from each other or
you just have Army Hammer and elucha
viander and you're you're cutting around
to like a lot of exposition about
Mission stuff that ultimately I was
starting to think like okay some of
these scenes that aren't um that aren't
like action or or just meant to be fun
is actually kind of messing with the
pacing of the film and it's not as
intriguing or interesting it just
wasn't and so I was I was like okay well
like the re cuz started having the
thought of like the it's not the mission
that makes the movie entertaining it's
it's the it's it's the uh actors
together that make that are making the
movie entertaining and it was around the
time when the mission when everything
started to actually coales and come
together in a way where the mission at
hand itself was interesting where there
was actual Stakes involved was after
Army Hammer and Henry caval do that
Breakin together and then then when the
mission continues okay now the mission
is actually interesting but it took a
while to get there I felt I felt like
okay it's taken a while for that stuff
to I know you got to do the setup and
everything and I just sort of feel like
the only parts of this movie that I
thought were a little bit um uh I don't
want to say tedious because tedious is
too harsh of a word just not as engaging
and and it felt like it was losing some
of its flare and and and pacing was was
in that first like first half of act two
I would say yeah but once we reached
that midpoint with them it was like okay
this movie is like firing on all
cylinders for me doesn't take its foot
off the pedal yeah there was that like
like you said that 15 20 minute stretch
there but after that yeah it was just
but it was also worth it because you
needed all that information for later I
just think maybe the immediate execution
of it could have been a little sharper
in the way it was done to make it all
thoroughly entertained because you
always had great actors in you're like
Jarry Harris I think is having an having
a ball of a time he's really fun yeah uh
the voices everyone's doing Hugh Grant
another great Edition Elizabeth dicki
surprised me as wow when she's here in
the last half of the film she is really
intimidating she's intimidating she's a
scary presence a lot of times um a role
like that might be given to like a guy
uh to making it more of a male character
and it just feels like a cliche
portrayal and she brought something very
different to it that I thought really
elevated and she is an interesting
character too cuz you can tell how piss
she was after Henry kill was going on
about how he killed her husband and it's
like and also at the same time she slept
with Henry Kev which like again he's a
very sve good-looking man and all but
it's like interesting relationship I
guess when you're that powerful and that
ruthless you just sleep around with
whoever you want but uh you know what I
think it is with Nolan and Richie is is
that Nolan usually tells like a unique
story still and I feel like guy Richie
takes at least from just these two films
he takes stories that are a little more
predictable and and and kind of go by
tropes and genre tropes of it but then
he executes them in a very unique way
yeah that's where I think his specialty
is like when you're getting the
backstory with the with the husband
torture he's slipping through the SC the
book and I'm like that's a really unique
way to instead of like cutting to the
footage you just see photographs telling
the tale yeah with like Uncle Rudy I
thought that was such a brilliant way of
telling the uh the back his backstory
even though that's a character like that
that we don't really give a [__] about
but still an interesting way to tell the
backstory uh I and obviously to the the
ending there was clearly set up for a
sequel so as Warrior uh we're filming
this we don't know why there is no
sequel I'm assuming box office um
because I feel like I mean got a 7.2 on
IMDb so I got to assume let's look up
some stuff then my friend okay the TV
series ran for four years got you for
like I Gotta Get You Out of Here Andrew
I know stop yelling at me I'll get you
out of here just wait we just want to
find the facts the facts on
MBA where are the facts on imba do you
see them a little lower know where
they're located I do right there oh my
God
genius
genius oh no
[__] you called that actually you called
that you said he he performed that cuz
at first they didn't show it I was like
oh I couldn't pull it off and then they
showed they showed the white shot you're
like yep he performed that holy [__]
that was wild they often perform their
own stunts I'm in with Henry caval I
yeah he's going to do that hammer was
more enthusiastic about his stunts to
the point the stunt double joke that he
hardly had a chance to do anything yeah
yeah I mean I that's what I mean by
those action scenes you you can actually
tell oh that is them doing that yeah I
do remember you calling that out too
like when uh we were on one of the chase
sequence is like holy [__] that's Henry
K driving right there kav admit he was
relieved to not have a shirtless scene
in this movie after stringing a movies
where had to be in top shape uh he was
glad to focus on his performance for
once and not his physique crazy cuz he
looks great sure yeah yeah I'm sure he
was looking at the script where the
shirtless scene okay I'm signing in for
signing up for this movie no sure David
Beckham
what Army Hammer was the only one who
watched the M from Uncle show from uh
for his role he was the only member to
do so that's funny oh is partially
developed by Ian Fleming oh so the bond
touch is very real you could feel it
aoleon solo has started as a character
and the in the novel of Goldfinger oh
interesting
cool uh
okay the tunnel say that's cool all
right yeah yeah I'm briefly some of
these are not interesting yes sure why
not there was the projectionist at the
beginning of the movie that was David
Beckham I guess so why did I not
recognize that damn it okay that tells
us nothing about why there's no sequel
hold on a second hold on box office
Maybe
okay is reportedly in the works
oh can you recap oh my God how funny
January 5th 2024 just this month
oh that's kind of funny how that was
like as we're doing as we're doing just
just so
recent uh there is movement on it okay
okay the disappointing box offers turns
they got mixed reviews that surprises me
so it's gained a following thanks to the
streaming okay
yeah that sucks about the box office
this this deserve better whatever but
the problem has come in the form of like
Army Hammer obviously yeah it's going to
be a public relations uh you're going to
have some problems there I mean here's
the
thing I think Army Hammer's really great
in the movie I do he's great he's great
but but I could the only thing that
would really be like I'm not going to
watch it if of course totally yeah yeah
I mean yeah would depend on who they get
I mean I guess I could see that but yeah
totally what you said if they re if they
didn't have Henry Cavo I'm not
interested well I had a blast with this
one Andrew um I hope you guys had fun
with it too do you want the Man from
Uncle sequel will you still watch it
even Army Hammer's not in it leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like um I don't know which guy
Rich probably the gentleman I would love
to see the gentleman I've heard such
good things about that movie and I've
never seen the trailer I don't know
anything about it so I'm like all right
if people are hyping the [__] up out of
that movie got to keep that guy Richie
experience going all right talk to you
guys
soon David
Gandy my
man I don't know what more there is to
say to you David except we haven't heard
from you in a while I know are you okay
did you get kidnapped it's going down a
very different path I was more like
guess you don't give a [__] about us
anymore you [__] yeah have you become
a jerk that's the worst fate of all your
subconscious instincts are very
different than mine not you go are you
okay are you concerned I go wow guy must
be a dick what an ass what a real jerk
this guy must be to neglect us who have
done so much for your life yeah we've
definitely done more for you than you've
ever name one thing you've done for us
out of the selflessness and kindness of
your own heart David you didn't drive
down forever just to see us live one day
you haven't given us countless gifts and
money on top like dined with us you know
broken bread with us literally and
figuratively we have slightly
entertained you and helped you pass some
time what greater gift is that what
greater gift than distraction but buddy
I don't know where you've been I don't
know why we haven't heard from you I
know we've been a lot busier since then
I feel like since the patreon's gotten
bigger and the Channel's g bigger some
of our ogs like yourself just don't
really like to chime in with us as much
anymore which I'm very grateful for
because I don't got the time to talk to
you anymore time to engage with to
really focus on your needs but dude
you've been an absolute blessing in our
lives and I I miss you man and if you're
ever down here in our neck of the woods
again because Lord knows I'm never make
it at to Arizona what the hell's there
to do stare at at Cactus boring as [__]
try stop the election what David's out
there doing right now he's photographing
just Cactus after Cactus Bing [__]
standing in that disgusting heat God
your life must be miserable now yeah
David what are you doing hell happens in
Arizona are you someone here listening
from
Arizona hate your life have at least a
couple of arizonians it can't just be
David Al David favorite on record
favorite Arizona right now David's just
standing next to his AC looking at us on
his phone yeah how boring and responding
to a video that won't respond back in
real time yeah stop man stop It Anyway
keep you in our prayers to the same God
we definitely believe in yeah and I hope
that uh I hope that everything's all
right in your neck of the woods yeah
keep on playing Tunes I think of you
every time I hear a
guitar or when I see a cactus or when I
see a cactus around here happens more
than you think my my flashback timeline
plays in linear order of the times we've
met and talk like a movie dve oh yeah I
see a cactus and I go right back to the
first
[Laughter]
memory a clip metal stuck in time anyway
miss you buddy hope you're doing
[Music]
well